now some of these strongest pressure on
the prime minister to ease the lockdown
and get the economy going again it's
actually coming from his own party and
we can speak now to one of the most
senior conservative backbenchers the
former brexit secretary David Davis
thank you for being on the program today
before we get to what we're expecting
from the prime minister I'm just
interested to get your thoughts on the
government's new slogan what do you make
of it well I don't want to see a policy
driven by slogans I mean one of the
difficulties we've had so far has been
certain amount of confusion about
messaging whether it's on mosques or
whatever what matters in this is the
detailed instruction so it's the same
for everybody that the police and the
government all say the same thing so I
don't mind stay alert I happen to think
that the government should rely more on
people's common sense and informed
decisions than on blanket rules so I
don't mind the change but frankly as far
as I'm concerned so the slogan is
secondary to the main policy there's
been some speculation that they stay at
home message was almost too successful
that people were staying at home when
actually it meant that they weren't
working and that of course has a
knock-on impact on the economy do you
think that's right yes understand every
every Western gun nearly about the Asian
government every Western government has
made mistakes on this and has had to
scramble to to get their policies in
place and early on of course it was very
rough and ready flatly I mean it was you
know you must do this and people
interpreted it sometimes over
interpreted the the instructions or
encouragement they were being given so
that's right but as we go along that's
where the scope for making this more
precise I mean mark great for talking
you earlier was saying you know if this
is not jobs versus lives he's right in
the sense of there are things we can do
which can save jobs and not jeopardize
lives there are other things we have to
do which would be dangerous if we put
jobs their lives so it's about precision
it's about care and attention to detail
and get us through the next several
several stages of this pox so let's talk
about some of those specifics what is it
that you're hoping to hear from the
prime minister late
well I'm hoping he's going to give us a
stage relaxation I'm hoping he's gonna
pay attention to some of the details I
mean let me give you an example of why I
say detailed matters as well as grand
strategies and grand targets earlier
this week maybe last week the the
chairman of the science selectivity
talking to one of the sage members asked
him you know what's this our number tell
us what's happening - zarnold gentleman
said that the only numbers gone up
really under lockdown why they said
because there's been more infection in
care homes so the answer to that problem
is not to generally tighten the lock
down the answer that problem may be
universal testing in here in care homes
it may be isolation of people working
here someone some care home workers have
already done that actually living in the
can so the attack on detail is as
important if not more important than the
ground strategy so that's number one
number two is I hope he gives enough
attention to the needs of families not
just the knees economy I'm brought
largely with Ritchie sooner I want to
see us get in the step right way back to
work but the families you know we know
that there are problems with domestic
violence and sometimes we know there are
tensions another we know there were
people who are disabled old at home and
he lonely and very depressed and these
services we know that people are
struggling with lots of children at home
not allowing to go to work or people
with disabled children all those issues
a marginal relaxation about family links
has been tried by other countries as far
as I can see without any hazard and I
would hope he would look at that as well
is that do you would you like to see a
situation where grandparents can see
their grandchildren for example I'm
biased me but yes I'd like to see a
thoughtful using the data using the
analysis from other countries I'd like
to see a thoughtful relaxation there may
be one family to one fan maybe a limited
number of people but however you do it
and you do that best off the empirical
data
from from other countries the one
advantage we have in all this is that
we're slightly at the back of the queue
so we can see what other countries are
done and what's being hazardous and
what's been effective and that's what we
should do and the problem is that
polling shows that most people think you
are basically on the wrong side of the
argument a Sky News poll at my YouGov
shade only 15 percent of people think
the Prime Minister should lift the
lockdown measures immediately it does
feel as if much of the polling that's
been done shows a lot of support for the
lockdown people are scared people want
the government to prioritize controlling
the virus getting that our number down
above lifting those measures well yes we
are history of it so far but the job of
the government is not to follow the
polls the job of the government is to do
the best thing for the country the polls
may change I mean I've seen this before
in other campaigns I've had with privacy
or on on foreign policy and that people
support something one day I mean the
Iraq war had something like 60 70
percent support the beginning the end of
your 80 percent comes up it's a terrible
idea
now what matters is not what the polls
say today what matters what the polls
will say in a year's time when we see
the impact of the policies and the job
of the government just not to follow the
polls not to fret about that but to
deliver safety on the one hand and
economic recovery and social stability
and health on the other so they can do
that they're beginning to get the data
there's more data becoming available
every day they can do that they
shouldn't fret about the boss or my
waiter never worried time popularity on
that data you concerned that some of the
data and the modeling that the
government has been basing its response
on so far is wrong yes very much so I
mean at the beginning of this I mean one
of the changes in the government's
policy seemed to be precipitated by in
particular the Imperial College model
the Niall Ferguson model which predicted
first five hundred thousand deaths then
if the day to later 250,000 death
and it's a model which has now been
widely criticized as badly constructed
full of errors and essentially for not
being reliable and also of course
previous runs of similar models by that
team have pretty much always
overestimated the death rate that's very
very important you get this sort of
thing right it's just because a number
comes out of a black box doesn't mean
it's right any more than any other
automated system use right and we've had
in other areas of life scandals where
it's the software have failed from auto
pilots through to well through all the
sorts of things written pretty sweet for
having a couple of breakups there on the
link to David Davis actually comes back
pretty quickly I think we may have to
leave it there for now apologies for
that I hope you've got most of that
interview with David Davis I hope